the big administration is really so
concerned about violence and domestic
terror then
why are they standing by while waves of
illegals flood the border and
they're not just migrant families
looking for sanctuary either
we're talking criminal cartels gangs
smugglers
human trafficking traffickers are all
capitalizing
on biden's border failures fox news
contributor raymond arroyo is in mcallen
texas
he's at the border he's been embedded
with texas law enforcement there raymond
laura last night we showed you how these
migrants are being used by the cartels
not only to make millions but to mask
their criminal activity
tonight we reveal how that activity is
spreading
into the united states into your
community and what
the texas state officials are doing
about it we start with a
wider and higher view of the border
flying with the texas department of
public safety
it's easy to see how vast this rio
grande sector really is
it's a wide open territory both to
migrants
and the cartels who control the mexican
side of the border
from the air the breaks in the border
wall and the uncompleted portions
are obvious on the ground border patrol
is forced to process
and care for an unending flood of
migrants
trafficked by the cartels meanwhile more
than 200
000 immigrants have escaped detection by
border patrol
so far this year and they're not all
families border patrol reports that
they've arrested
more border crossers with criminal
records in fiscal year 2021
then 2019 and 2020 combined
and that is no mistake state of texas is
taking matters into its own hands
with operation lone star state law
enforcement and national guardsmen
are moving against the cartels just
yesterday
border patrol working with the texas
department of public safety
busted up this stash house more than a
hundred
migrants were hiding within lieutenant
christopher oliveiras
of the texas department of public safety
yeah so as you can see here
uh you can see they've been here
probably for numerous days
you see various clothing water bottles
you know makeshift mattresses where they
sleep on
you can see the conditions here are very
poor unsanitary there's no
air circulation there's no central air
so
especially with the south texas heat it
can be
pretty dangerous in here as far as these
migrants in here i'll say how do they
continue to enforce
their their uh power over these people
in the united states they're in control
of them these people cannot move
inland they cannot move anywhere else in
the country until the cartel says
they're allowed to move to now until
they pay their fee whatever they owe the
cartels in order to get further inland
the cartels are in constant motion these
smugglers
trafficking people into the u.s were
pursued by texas highway patrol
in a high-speed chase this is just one
of more than 370 pursuits
since march earlier this week a smuggler
smashed into a mcallen home
trying to escape authorities and these
criminals are not
only transporting people this is just
one of many seizures that are
that our dps personnel have seized this
particular individual
he wasn't documented he was in the
country illegally i mean he was in
possession of these firearms which were
destined for mexico there's no
serial markings on there oh they don't
have serial numbers why are these bagged
up like this in these
sealed packages so those are broken down
so they can be smuggled into mexico
tell me you all recently made a big drug
discovery um
i guess it was hidden out tell me about
that they use they'll move their drugs
across the river
and they'll stash them in into the brush
area and they'll have their driver it's
very strategic they have their drivers
drive up
load up the drugs and then they'll take
them to a stash house for drugs for
narcotics or special operations group
working with us border patrol and they
were able to discover that large seizure
was approximately 400 pounds of
marijuana
since march texas authorities have
seized over 11
000 pounds of weed and nearly 600 pounds
of meth
and cocaine as well as nearly a million
dollars
having all this happen in the thriving
city of mcallen
is unsettling to the mayor javier
villalobos
it has caused the strain it has caused
some conflict within the community
itself
and of course taxpayer money we have no
reason or
our municipality has no reason to be
expending money on a federal issue
we are focused on the criminal element
that is a threat
to the southern border that is a threat
to the country because
we cannot lose focus on these cartels
they're exploiting the situation they
know what they're doing they're
distracting
the american people by you know the
surge of migrants that are coming across
but yet you see stash houses you see
narcotics you see weapons you see
currency
that is the threat right now and that's
what we need to focus on
laura we focus on the border we focus on
texas but this
is a national problem it's coming to
your community and it's already there
by the way drug seizures here in texas
are up 56 percent fentanyl
800 percent from last year and these
border agents these law enforcement
officials
they are endangered by this policy at
the border as well
another under reported part of this
story
raymond thank you for that report eye
opening and disturbing
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else